this better work always does all right
everybody let's start to shut your
mouths
shoveling here chairs god this chair
sucks huh okay listen up now you listen
up you don't want to choose just biology
and we know you used to teach philosophy
Oh weeping shut up shut up no no no
strip stop bring the music off turn it
off
[Music]
take your seats
wait nuts don't ever surprise me with a
rap don't ever rap about learning oh boy
oh no you had a saxophone solo and your
rap yeah that's too bad don't you come
on there big guy toss that puppy in the
trash for me yeah good saxophones do not
belong in rap music you were gonna make
it rain huh what notebooks part of the
rap thing no all right
now look I realize I haven't been making
the most of your time but that is gonna
start to change as of right now as I
mentioned I've been trying to mentally
break my nemesis miles Leonard he
currently has the job that is rightfully
mine and I want it back he seems to be
winning at the moment but by the time
we're done with him he's gonna be in a
loony bin begging for death don't you
think you'd have a better chance of
getting the job if you focused on
working hard as opposed to trying to
make him go crazy you see my actions are
justified because they produce a better
outcome than any other action in this
particular case it's a basic philosophy
Act utilitarianism Jeremy Bentham stop
writing that down now I happen to know
that Myles is currently single so your
assignment for today is to catfish him
on his Facebook page you guys wait for
catfish right a flirty Facebook message
you know using a fake name you call
yourself like Linda and we'll send the
best one to miles all right look at this
point you guys should all be catfishing
or dead asleep
[Applause]
old dude handle slightly less shut up
that's everyone shut your mouths now and
settle into your chairs all right let's
hear some of these catfish messages you
want to start please no all right Prince
of Darkness see you working on something
over there what you got dere miles you
don't know me but you will we will marry
under the black son of Satan's breath
I'll be the final face you see as I wrap
my hands around your neck and suck your
soul into my mouth Wow somebody alert
the authorities I mean no I'm kidding
I'm joking it's great really
it's very descriptive you know maybe
just make it a little bit more female
uh-huh all right you I want to hear
something from you
hey boy here's louder hey boy you're
smooth like butter dripping off of
chocolate I'm gonna lick you up and down
drip slurp yummmm give me that sweet
with sugar mess now let's do keep in
mind that this will be the first message
that miles be hearing from a total
stranger
but yes great start good mr. Griffin oh
wow you snuck up on me yeah I put in
your request for the new chair and so
that's in front of the board now okay
great well let me know how they vote all
right this is biology oh absolutely
sugar right yeah we're in the middle of
it take care now whoa look at the prince
of d going strong over there give us
another snippet and fire and blood will
pour from my eyes as I gaze upon your
ravaged body by the way I am a female
demon I see a lot of myself in you
you aren't going places Devin guys are
pretty good at this yeah I'm fun yeah
all right who's next
dear miles I want to make you blush make
you feel safe I want to lay next to you
and laugh until we cry I want to grow
old together and when we're old will say
I don't mind because I have you
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about guys give
it up all right let's go home but we
have other classes all right whatever
[Music]
do it slurp YUM give me that sweet wet
sugar mess well hello
you